hey 42 here australia
is home to some truly nightmarish
creations
and no i don't mean neighbors which has
inexplicably been on british tv for over
30 years
i'm talking about wildlife the kind you
can only find
in the lands down under snakes that can
kill you in an instant
spiders the size of your head and a
variety of other creatures that would
rip out your intestines
and eat your face as soon as you look at
it
with that in mind you'd think that if
the australian government
ever decided to declare all-out war on
one of the creatures that roamed their
beautiful land
it would be on something venomous
carnivorous
or at the very least mildly bad tempers
but no in perhaps the greatest version
of man vs beast
ever recorded the aussies went after
the emu the ensuing struggle was so
bloody
it is today known as the great emu war
of 1932 and no
i'm not making that up but you can see
why the government would want to go to
town on these fearsome creatures can't
you
just look at them the baleful dead eyes
the small but probably very deadly beak
the stubby legs that could quite happily
kick your elderly grandmother to death
but actually the reasons for wanting to
commit mass
emu side were a bit more complicated
than that
after world war one the government
decided to give their discharged
veterans some land in western australia
so they could live out their days as
farmers have a bit of peace and quiet
and try to forget all about the horrors
of war
it sounded good on paper but in reality
it didn't quite turn out to be the
utopia the veterans had expected
the land was unfertile and the farming
hard
backbreaking work and then the great
depression arrived in 1929 to make
things even worse
wheat prices fell precipitously the
government failed to follow through on
promised subsidies for farmers
and then in 1932 just to add insults to
injury
the emus turned up 20 000
of them and what was worse they were
hungry for the sweet taste of man flesh
well okay wheat but still they were
hungry
you could even say they were peckish
mind you this wasn't the first time the
emus had made themselves known to man
far from it up until 1922 emus had been
a protected species
but they were soon reclassified as
vermin after it became clear
they had no respect for social etiquette
emus
you see don't have a firm grasp on the
concept of
farming through the eyes of an emu a
farm is basically
a very convenient kind of
all-you-can-eat buffet
but farming in western australia is hard
enough as it is
so when a horde of weird-looking birds
comes along
to joyfully munch through the literal
fruits of your labor
you aren't going to lie down and take it
so
in 1923 a bounty system was introduced
offering cash for every emu killed
it seemed like a good idea at the time
and it probably would have worked pretty
well
if it hadn't been for the numbers these
ex-military farmers were all well
trained with a rifle of course
but even with all human killing
expertise
they were unable to slow the wave of
feathered enemies
heading towards them across no man's
land
they simply didn't have enough ammo
by the time 1932 rolled around it had
become abundantly clear that unless
someone invented
a bomb that specifically vaporized emus
the farmers were going to need more guns
specifically of the large fully
automatic variety
soon enough several of these ex-soldiers
were knocking on minister of defense sir
george pierce's door
asking for more firepower feather
penetrating rounds
beak-seeking missiles and of course
a lot more emunition okay so they didn't
ask for any of those things
for reasons i can't explain they appear
to have had almost
no interest whatsoever in puns but they
did ask for machine guns with which to
battle their emu opponents
and amazingly the government agreed not
only providing the weapons in the form
of two lewis guns
but also sending in the army to wheels
them
the transport of fresh soldiers was paid
for by the western australian government
and the farmers provided food
accommodation and paid for the
ammunition
it was probably overkill but as far as
pierce was concerned
the birds would provide good target
practice for his men
and the feathers could be used to make
hats for the light horsemen
after all if you're killing thousands of
birds with two machine guns
you might as well kill two birds with
one stone
whilst you're at it the operation was
led by major gpw meredith
of the seventh heavy battery of the
royal australian artillery
and if the amount of syllables in a
person's title are any indication of his
emu murdering capabilities
then he was certainly the man for the
job
in october of 1932 he took two soldiers
from his battery
along with two lewis guns and ten
thousand rounds of ammo
and headed off to assist the farmers
during the first
day however the war was cooled off
by rain which admittedly makes it sound
more like a tennis match at wimbledon
than a serious military campaign you
couldn't imagine hitler saying
hold on lads our panzers are getting
damp
let's invade poland tomorrow anyway this
unexpected downpour made the enemy
scatter which was a significant problem
because when you're trying to fire a
barrage of machine gun bullets into a
crowd of emus
you really don't want them to start
valuing their personal space
but by the 2nd of november hostilities
had resumed once more
it was at this point meredith and his
men attempted to herd about 50 emus
into a small area to make sure they were
in range of the guns
but the emus appeared to cotton onto
this plan and responded by employing
their own version of guerilla tactics
scattering into
smaller units so they were difficult to
target on mass
even so a stubby little beak versus a
machine gun
isn't exactly a fair fight and sadly
quite a few valiant birds lost their
lives that day
but it took so many bullets to do the
job that questions began to be asked as
to whether the whole
machine gun the emus thing was
economically viable
maybe financial warfare was part of the
emu's battle plan all along
although they've never been known for
their accountancy skills
either way meredith had obviously vastly
underestimated the enemy
not only were they becoming increasingly
difficult to hit
but when his men did manage to shoot one
most of the birds seemed to just
take it in their stride so much so that
it was taking an average of 10
bullets to bring down a single emu
although admittedly most of those shots
missed their mark in the first place
major meredith later said if we had a
military with the bullet-carrying
capacity of these birds
it would face any army in the world they
can face machine
guns with the invulnerability of tanks
and if that's true why were they still
using tanks in world war
ii shouldn't the allies have ditched
their armoured vehicles and ridden into
berlin on emus instead
the war of man vs feathery beast
continued
but frankly by this point it was a
comedy of errors
the next thing meredith did was to set
up an ambos
near a local dam and on the 4th of
november
over a thousand emus were spotted
heading towards it
everything was going swimmingly all they
had to do was wait until those beaky
bastards were close enough
and opened fire but as the birds finally
got within range
the lewis guns jammed and only 12 emus
were killed
whilst arrest legged it yet another day
in the great emu war of 1932 was over
without too much to write home about
meredith was clearly struggling to match
wits with his
emu equivalent and as crazy as it may
sound
it really did seem like the enemy were
operating under orders
in fact several days into the war
observers noted that each pack of emus
appeared to have its own general a big
guy about six foot high
with black feathers who calls the shots
and kept watch
whilst the other emus helped themselves
to crops and
is it just me or do you imagine him
wearing a battle scarred helmet on his
tiny head
cigar clamped tightly in his beak and
saying things like
i love the smell of napalm in the
morning
no just me then out of frustration
or maybe pure desperation the army
mounted one of the lewis guns on a truck
and tried to mow down the emus that way
the emus however were like usain bolt's
hot speed
not only that but the ride was so bumpy
the gunner in the back was unable to
fire off any shots
at one point a particularly brave
kamikaze emu
who managed to get his corpse caught in
the truck steering equipment
causing the driver to steer into
somebody's fence which promptly
disintegrated
and in western australia fences were
pretty damn
important which was another reason emus
had to be sacrificed on the altar of
agriculture
you see emu's not only destroyed the
crops
they also left gaps in fences where
rabbits could get through
so what i hear you ask what's the big
deal about a few cute fluffy bunnies
well rabbits are a very big deal in us
hence the rabbit prefence which runs for
700 kilometers across western australia
they're a significant factor in species
loss and have a huge impact on both
natural resources and
crops due to the fact they graze like a
fat manatee wedding
mind you the rabbit fence hasn't done a
fantastic job of bunny massacring
because they're still a problem in the
1950s the mexoma virus which causes
mexiomatosis
was deliberately introduced into the
rabbit population in australia
this cut down numbers for a while but
the rabbits have since developed
immunity
allowing them to keep on breeding like
well
like rabbits could the great rabbit war
be next
only time will tell by the 8th of
november 1932
2500 shots had been fired
in the great emu war all of them by the
human side i should add
but the number of emus killed was only
in the hundreds with some claiming it
was as low as 50.
still it wasn't all doom and gloom
because meredith made a note in his
official report
sounding particularly proud of himself
that not one of his men had been
injured during the battle which is a
miracle when you think about it
i mean those poor men were left to face
a massive placid flightless birds all on
their own
with nothing but machine guns to defend
themselves
it's a miracle any of those boys got out
alive
perhaps unsurprisingly it was also
around this point meredith started
losing the support of the local media
they were making quite a big deal of the
fact that only a few emus were dying
especially given the rambo-esque levels
of firepower being brought to bear
it also didn't help that serious
questions were being asked in parliament
for example when one politician
suggested medals should be awarded to
those brave soldiers taking part in the
emu war
a member of the opposition said the
medal should be given to the emus
instead as
they'd won every round so far
if the agricultural ramifications hadn't
been so
serious meredith and his men could
easily have become a laughingstock
defence minister george pearce who'd
agreed to the whole thing in the first
place
was even given the unofficial title
minister for the emu war
which could hardly have been a feather
in the cap of his military career
still he kept on defending the operation
and with support from the premiere of
western australia
it was agreed battle would recommence
on the 13th of november bullets were
flying once again
and by the 2nd of december the military
were killing around 100 emus per week
that was definitely an
improvement but it was hardly putting a
dent in the mass ranks of emus
and by 1934 the higher-ups in government
were clearly
at the end of their feather i mean teva
i'll stop now i promise the bounty
system was reintroduced and the farmers
were given enough ammunition to take
care of the issue themselves
which proved to be pretty effective
because over 57
000 bounties were claimed in the
following six
months mind you there must still have
been a fair few emus knocking around
because
in 1943 wheat farmers were concerned
enough to request military assistance
with the growing eemi threat
once again and apparently having learnt
from the debacle with the lewis guns
this time the farmers had a better idea
they wanted the army
to bring bombs lots of bombs
i'm happy to say the military
respectfully declined
the invitation but the emu problem
wasn't going away
and in 1950 it was raised in federal
parliament
where army minister josiah francis
approved the release
of 500 000 rounds of ammunition
to help with the claiming of bounties
all told
around 300 000 emus were killed in
western australia
as part of the great emu war and the
skirmishes that followed
but who really won the great emu war of
man or emu it's true
a lot of emus were sent to meet their
beaky maker
and so far as we know not one human
combatants died in the line of duty
but even so the emus put up a remarkably
good fight considering the circumstances
these days the majestic emu appears on
the australian coat of arms
which is more than you can say for major
gpw meredith
and in 2020 a video game was released
based around the emu war
but i've yet to see a game set in the
western australian parliament
perhaps the greatest victory of all
however is that the emu is still with us
and it's thankfully now illegal for
anyone to murder them with
machine guns bombs or anything else for
that matter
so maybe that sarcastic politician was
right
maybe the emus should have been given a
medal after all
and maybe we should have a day of
remembrance for those emus
who lost their lives defending their
right
to eat their own body weight in wheat
maybe we can convince christopher nolan
to make a movie about it like he did
with dunkirk
i'm sure tom hardy would make a
fantastic emu
thanks for watching you can now buy my
new book stick a flag in it on amazon
or get the audio book on audible you'll
find a link to both in the description
below
thank you